mathieu belliard et votre invité sonia
mabrouk c'est christian jacob le
président du parti les républicains
député de seine et marne bienvenue ce
matin sur europe 1 et bonjour christian
jacob bourgeot il faut dessiner un
nouveau chemin dit emmanuel macron ça
vous rassure ou ça vous inquiète
les plutôt le sentiment que c'est une
nouvelle impasse qu'ils entendent
dessiner le président dela le poison de
la république
moi honnêtement sur 7 sur cette
interview difficile de s'y retrouver en
doutons on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il a
plus les ressorts politiques n'a plus
les ressorts politiques parce que c'est
l'échec le plus cuisant aux municipales
jamais un président de la république qu
un tel échec aux élections municipales
c'est l'absence totale de tout ancrage
sur le terrain c'est une majorité
parlementaire qui a explosé il ya
maintenant quatre voire cinq groupes
pour arriver à composer la la majorité
et puis est ce qu'il a
est-ce qu'il a encore l'énergie et
l'ambition les questions se posent
désormais oui apparemment la réforme des
retraites dans une version remaniée aura
lieu prévient-il à ce que la volonté
toujours là selon vous de réformes et
écouter sur les retraites ça a été trois
ans d'échecs trois ans d'échecs nous dit
aujourd'hui qui va reprendre les
concertations là où il a échoué pendant
trois ans avant la crise et donc après
la crise sera en situation de le faire
les retraites la réforme des retraites
pour nous les choses ont toujours été
très clair vous avez trois leviers
d'actions soit vous baisser les pensions
des retraités nous nous y sommes
totalement opposés parce que quand on a
cotisé quarante ans on allait légitimité
pour pouvoir bénéficier de sa retraite
donc nous sommes opposés à baisser les
pensions et belle macro dit il va
falloir travailler plus longtemps à
roulers soit on augmente les cotisations
et donc à ce moment-là vous plomber le
pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui travaillent
et la compétitivité des entreprises donc
le seul moyen de le faire
c'est effectivement d'allonger la durée
de cotisation c'est ce que nous avons
toujours dit clairement depuis le début
et nous sommes sur cette ligne là
maintenant est ce que le président de la
république a la capacité politique de
mener cette réforme est en train de dire
ce matin christian jacob qu'une réforme
des retraites sans l'âge pivot n'est
plus une réforme des retraites si je
vous comprends bien si on allonge pas la
durée de cotisation ça sert à rien je
vous dis les trois leviers c'est soit
baisser les pensions de dd retraités
soient augmentés les brigitte jolivet
l'indre fait un diagnostic d'avant crise
sanitaire est ce qu'on peut encore
réformé comme vous le dites et réformer
en profondeur dans un tel contexte
économique et social au jour grippe et
donc en creux si le président de la
république dit qu'il repose la réforme
des retraites sans allonger la durée de
cotisation
ça veut dire qu'il pose la réforme des
retraites pour baisser les pensions des
retraités et pour augmenter les
cotisations de ceux qui travaillent
c'est c'est une impasse c'est une
impasse de dire aujourd'hui est-ce que
l'urgence est d'aller baisser les
pensions des retraités
est-ce que l'urgence est d'aller
augmenter les cotisations et donc de
baisser le salaire net est de baisser la
compétitivité des entreprises
cette réforme il n'a pas été capable de
la porter en trois ans comment en une
année utile qui lui reste aujourd'hui
serait capable de la porter fini les
jours heureux emmanuel macron prévient
chris engins câble que la rentrée sera
très rude c'est du réalisme pour
préparer les esprits à écouter ça pour
le coup c'est ça point qu'on partage
avec le président la république
effectivement au lendemain de ce crise
la situation est difficile tout le monde
le reconnaît volontiers
mais pourquoi les difficiles parce qu
aucune réforme de structure n'a été
menée 50 socialisme trois ans de macron
quelles réformes défense elle aussi créé
saint jacob reconnaissant le parce qu'on
est passé par une crise inédite scènes
évidemment mais bien évidemment mais on
est beaucoup moins bien préparés que
d'autres en regardons les résultats
économiques
nous avons le pire déficit public de
toute la zone euro nous avons le pire
déficit commercial de l'union européenne
nous avons le 25e taux de croissance sur
on atteint un niveau d'endettement
historique avant le avant le locaux
vides et le taux record des prélèvements
obligatoires à 48%
ce qui veut dire que pendant les trois
ans du début du quinquennat
aucune réforme de structure n'a été
menée et s'est inscrit dans la
continuité de françois hollande
donc nous expliquer maintenant on rase
gratis et on va réussir ou en 18 mois ou
en un an ce qu'on n'a pas fait en trois
ans le doute est permis
peut-être qu'il ya un point positif et
là vous rejoignez le président de
république sur les régionales il n'y
aura pas de report semble-t-il il ne
veut pas en tous les cas imposer et seul
un calendrier la csé du bon sens oui ça
peut battre les dates d'élection c'est
pas le fait du prince
j'avais eu l'occasion de le de le dire
d'ailleurs je crois sur votre antenne et
je maintiens c'est cette position c'est
réaliste parce que quand vous reporter
les élections des collectivités
territoriales ça veut dire que vous
bloquez l'investissement public et
l'investissement public est déterminant
sur la création d'emplois donc c'était
vraiment n'importe quoi d'aller faire
une combine politicienne
donc s'il a renoncé à ça c'est très bien
emmanuel macron qui louent christian
jacob une relation de confiance
historique inédite avec son premier
ministre une fois qu'on a dit cela
pourquoi on lui demandera de partir bah
je sais pas s'il va lui demander de
partir vous savez pour voir s'il serait
logique qu'il reste et je vous comprends
bien la logique c'est
qu'est ce que le président de la
république va faire pour relancer
l'économie notre notre pays
après une crise sanitaire aussi grave
que celle que nous venons de subir
savait que des incarnations c'est
important avoue dans un parti
bonapartiste comme vous vous savez que
c'est important d'être important non
mais avant de savoir qu'ils ont mais à
la barre du bateau il est important de
savoir où on va c'est qu'il ne sait pas
où il va je compte bien s'en remettre à
un nouveau chemin c'est des phrases que
dire des bons concrètement moi je ne
sais pas où le président de la
république va donc pour ce qui est
composé le gouvernement
on lui fait confiance vous savez il
ouvrira le gotha mondain il va bien
trouver du monde à mettre dans le
gouvernement
mais quels cas pour aller où pour porter
quelles réformes donc voilà la situation
et là ya pas de réponse dans l'interview
entraîneur philippe et les républicains
s'est terminée la rupture est consommée
définitive christian jacob
bah écoutez c'est edouard philippe qui a
décidé de 2,2 à question à vous il a
trahi sa famille politique
il réalise en il a conduit une politique
qui qui a qui a conduit à l'impasse que
je viens d'évoquer les résultats
économiques sont là pour en témoigner
et on ne parle que des résultats
économiques on peut parler de la
sécurité et re re on est dans une
situation catastrophique on peut
reparler du du régalien de cette
politique c'est edouard philippe qui l'a
conduit avec le président de la
république nous est nous sommes des
opposants à cette politique et nous
avons d'ailleurs été en opposant
responsable à chaque fois nous avons été
force de proposition mais je m'entraîne
bien je vous opposer au cap aucun
économique mais est ce que vous lui
reconnaissait à edouard philippe une
stature d'homme d'état
non mais moi je reconnais saturday
d'edouard philippe le sujet pas là
simplement l'esprit d'en parler ainsi
il a conduit une politique que nous
combattons est-ce que servir la france
c'est pour autant qu est-ce que servir
la france c'est trahir lui dans son
esprit il sert son pays
oui mais en fait il le sert sur un cap
qui est mauvais il est dans la
continuité de françois hollande
donc je vais pas vous dire que c'est la
bonne quantité c'est la ligne politique
que nous que nous défendons ça retire
rien aux qualités humaines d'edouard
philippe bien et vise à redire que ce
matin le sujet pouvait nous dire avec
certitude qui ne sera pas un jour votre
candidat s'il le souhaite qu'il ne sera
jamais votre recours providentiel
ah bah non c'est pour le moins n'est pas
providence y réussir écoutez oui je le
dis mais très clairement j'ai dit cours
d'une politique bien l'opposé de celle
que nous souhaitons donc je peux pas
va dire mieux il trahi sa famille
politique pour aller aux côtés d'edouard
philippe et s'inscrire dans la
continuité de l'action économique de
françois hollande
non effectivement se retrouve pas dans
la politique à tous mais il en rire oh
rien ses qualités personnelles
succession pourrait rejoindre le
gouvernement à la faveur de ce
remaniement si je vous entends bien
crise en jacob seront des entre
guillemets évidemment des traîtres 12 et
10 le président de la république qui va
ouvrir le bottin mondain il va bien
trouver du monde pourrait d'ores et déjà
les républicains comment il peut trouver
dénoncé le sujet il est pas là encore
une fois une interview pourquoi dire
pourquoi faire direction marseille mais
c'est le patron des républicains en rien
ne se passe comme ailleurs martine
vassal en quelques mots à nos auditeurs
jette l'épongé passe le relais au
bénéfice de l'âge députés aient l'air
guy teissier 75 ans oui mais un autre
élu et l'air lionel royer perreaut
déclare sa candidature et dénonce un
accord avec leur assemblée nationale
clairement ce matin est ce qu'il ya eu d
un accord à ce qu'ils aient eu des
contacts avec le rassemblement national
et la droite
absolument aucun et les hors de question
qu'il y en ait là les choses ont
toujours été très clair aucun accord
aucune discussion ni avec le front
national ni avec l'extrême gauche
nous avons toujours rejeté les
politiques d extrême c'est très clair la
situation à marseille ne nous la
connaissons bien malheureusement nous
avons une dissidence on a soutenu
investi martine vassal lyon qui a obtenu
39 sièges une dissidence avec bruno gil
qui a obtenu 3 sièges
martine vassal et bruno gilles se sont
rassemblés donc 39 +3 ça fait 42
c'est le score du printemps marseillais
où il y à l'extrême gauche qui est
dedans donc on a 42 42 ans carnet en cas
d'égalité
lorsqu il y a et égalité des voix c'est
le doyen d'âge c'est la raison pour
laquelle martine vassal s'est retirée
donc voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
n'est aimé secret singes rap qui vous
soutenez est-ce que vous soutenez guy
teissier ou est-ce que vous soutenez ce
nouveau candidat lionel royer perreaut
42 42 royer perreaut de part son état
civil ne peut pas être élu guy teissier
mais bien évidemment aucun accord aucun
accord avec le front national nous a des
liens avec l'extrême gauche
ben moi je vous donne ma position
interrogés les choses sont sans
ambiguïté on ne peut pas accepter un
accord avec les extrêmes extrême gauche
comme extrême qui légitiment guy
teissier est de venir peut-être maire de
marseille ça peut s'apparenter comme un
déni de démocratie
écoutez ça ce sont c'est une élection
après faut faire le procès du mode de
scrutin du parti non mais met d'accord
mais le mode d'élection est celui-là
c'est à dire que c'est une élection en
deux temps avec ces scrutins
d'arrondissement honnêtement c'est pas
le meilleur scrutin mais enfin c'est
comme ça moi même monde d'avant un temps
il
mais la loi est comme ça elle n'a pas
été changé donc j'y peux rien et donc ça
nous amène à ce résultat 42 42 égalité
cissé égalité c'est le doyen d'âge qui
gagne et martine vassal fait un geste
responsable qui est pas facile pour elle
le donne de suis vraiment d'avant oui
mais oui mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
le il faut complètement mais il faut
changer le mode de scrutin de paris lyon
et marseille
nous en sommes convaincus mais nous ne
l'avons pas fait à tort lorsqu'on est au
pouvoir et depuis huit ans ça n'a pas
été fait merci christian jacob d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur
europe 1 et bonne journée